Oh,
so jocelyn bells,
it's the lady who discovered pulsars
that they've got the Nobel prize.
And she was here talking to the students
just a couple of years ago because she's
now a very distinguished scientist.
This,
she discovered pass,
but 40 years ago.
And,
and uh,
anyway,
uh,
students for asking,
how are you?
Sorry you didn't get the Nobel prize.
And she said,
Oh,
no,
I've been all my life.
I've just been famous for not having no,
but the Nobel prize,
that was actually much better.
I think she's right.
I mean,
you know,
it's much better if people ask,
why didn't you get the prize?
It's much better than if they're asking,
why did you get it?
Well,
I would say bringing up six kids and who
are all productive citizens and.